- [Host] Located on the steep hillsides
in Chongqing, China are the
ancient rock carvings of Dazu.
(upbeat pop music)
With more than 60,000 figures,
the Dazu carvings are one of the largest
and most spectacular collections
of ancient sculpture work in the world.
The carvings date back
to the Ninth Century,
featuring imagery from Buddhism,
Taoism, and Confucianism,
which highlights the peaceful coexistence
of the three religions in ancient China.
In addition to the religious themes,
there are statues of everyday
domestic and farming life
from the same period.
Aesthetically, the rock carvings
are animated in appearance,
and reflect traditional Chinese culture,
emphasizing learning from the past.
The site wasn't open to
visitors until the 1960s,
when Chinese nationals were given access.
20 years later, the
carvings were made available
to the general public,
and around the turn of the century,
it was declared a UNESCO
World Heritage Site.
The organization cited the
statues aesthetic quality,
their rich diversity of subject matter,
and the light they shed on everyday life
in China during this period.
(gentle pop music)